jarrett wade brumet
asks
going off of the study you shared
earlier this week
i'd really like to hear what the
literature says about what the general
public should do to improve the
likelihood of maintaining weight loss i
think the study he's referring to
was a study we shared uh from the
instagram account which was previously a
mass research brief on um
resistance training independently
reducing visceral fat uh even in the
absence of a
purposeful caloric deficit
i assume i i assume that's what's being
referenced
or maybe a better question what's the
literature say to be predicting factors
of regain that people should address
when attempting weight loss maybe this
was about something you posted i don't
know
whatever
basically what what factors
predict successful weight loss
maintenance i think that's essentially
what's being asked here
um and so i the the first place my brain
went to answer this question was to the
national weight control registry what
that is uh it's it's an american thing
and you can apply to be a part of the
registry if you're at least 18 years old
and have lost at least 30 pounds and
have maintained it for at least a year
so it's essentially a thing that you can
just
opt into and and that is one thing to
note it's not a perfectly representative
sample of everyone who's lost weight
it's a representative sample of everyone
who's lost weight and knows what the
national weight control registry is and
wants to tell you about it and wants to
tell you about it so you know this may
not be the perfect sample for answering
this question but i i think it's
one of the better ones that exists yeah
uh so with that caveat out of the way um
within the national weight control
registry
uh they say there is a variety in how
national weight control registry members
keep the weight off uh most report
continuing to maintain a low-calorie
low-fat diet and doing high levels of
activity
and then just some notes 78 percent eat
breakfast every day 75 weigh themselves
at least once a week 62 percent watch
less than 10 hours of tv per week and 90
percent
on average at least one hour per day
i don't know
the degree to which all of those things
are necessarily causal i don't
necessarily know that a
low-fat diet is better than a low-carb
diet for maintaining weight loss i don't
necessarily think that eating breakfast
every day is important so keep in mind
those are those are correlative things
not causal things people in the national
weight control registry those are the
things that they report doing
but one of the things from
really every line of research i've seen
looking at weight loss maintenance that
seems to be
a very important factor is exercise
um you know you were just talking a
second ago about how how cool exercises
and all of its benefits and i think that
exercise gets kind of a bad rap in some
circles for its impact on weight loss
because
the research that's out there looking at
the impact of just exercise on
weight loss itself
isn't that promising like if you take
people
uh you know just pluck them out of the
general population and say hey you're
going to start exercising like doesn't
matter if it's high intensity interval
training doesn't matter if it's cardio
doesn't matter if it's resistance
training
whatever generally what you see is like
maybe they'll lose a couple pounds but
not many it doesn't seem to be an
effective
exercise only interventions don't seem
to be
effective standalone interventions for
a large amount of long-term weight loss
but
exercise does seem to be very important
for weight loss maintenance um
and i i think that there are some
reasons for that
one
is uh actually
i could i could talk about this for a
long time but i think the biggest reason
why exercise is important for weight
loss maintenance um
you know on on top of it just generally
being good for you is exercise seems to
regulate your hunger pretty well so
um you have
kind of homeostatic
uh weight mechanisms within your body
where
if everything is working appropriately
even without tracking your your
nutritional intake
on average for most people if you're
reasonably active
your
felt caloric needs should
comport pretty well with your actual
caloric needs for weight maintenance
um but if you're reasonably sedentary
those homeostatic weight regulatory
factors can kind of get out of whack and
so basically you just wind up being
hungrier than you need to be for the
actual
number of calories that you're expending
per day so
um
you know i i think a lot of people who
lose weight and then keep it off do
also do some degree of purposeful
nutritional regulation whether that's a
particular type of diet whether that's
counting calories like there's a lot of
um there's a lot of methods people go
with to lose the weight and and keep it
off on the nutritional side of things
but exercise just makes all of that work
better because if you're exercising and
you're in a small calorie deficit you'll
probably be less hungry than if you're
not exercising any and you're in a small
calorie deficit and then when you've
lost a lot of weight and you're trying
to keep it off
maintenance when you're when you've lost
a lot of fat leptin levels are low
hunger is probably going to be elevated
exercise can kind of take the edge off
of that and help those homeostatic
hunger regulatory factors just work
better um
so yeah
you know reducing sedentary time so a
lot of these people report not watching
a ton of television i think that's
important uh 75 weigh themselves at
least once per week you know i i think
uh that kind of goes to the to the adage
of what gets measured gets managed like
keeping an awareness of your weight so
it doesn't start creeping back up i
think that's probably pretty important
uh but i i think if you were trying to
narrow it down to just one thing um
exercise seems to be like
regularly exercising and not being
sedentary seems to be uh quite important
yeah and if i could add one thing to
kind of tie some concepts together
because i think if people are taking
notes and they should be i often say
people should take notes when they
listen to the show
they'll notice we've said a few things
that on the surface sound to be a bit
contradictory so
we talked about how the interference
effect doesn't have a notable impact on
hypertrophy we've also talked about how
generally speaking being you know having
a high physical activity level can help
regulate hunger in
a caloric deficit in the context of
weight loss
but
when i was talking about cardio during
prep one of the things i kind of
mentioned as an aside was
potentially
how that can impact hunger responses in
people doing physique prep
and i think it's really important to
highlight that the distinction there is
the physiological context of doing
contest prep so
if the concurrent training literature
was all done in people who were four and
a half percent body fat and training
their ass off and in a caloric deficit
i think we might see something going on
with hypertrophy yeah um and
one of the things we see with
key drivers of hyperphagia the really
pronounced hunger that occurs
in you know physique or bodybuilding
prep one of the key drivers of
hyperphagia is the loss of fat-free mass
and so that's why you have to take these
c these statements about the
interference effect and the relationship
between physical activity and hunger
those are
generally speaking you know the the more
generalizable approaches to to those
topics or kind of conclusions there but
when you put those into the context of
someone who is
doing contest prep
shredded caloric deficit
all their hormones are out of whack
their hypothalamus is completely checked
out and they're overdoing their cardio
now we see a slightly different response
to how that excess or that excessive
cardio can impact their hunger
management so i just wanted to i wanted
to make sure whenever i'm listening to a
podcast and something at the beginning
and something at the end seem
contradictory and they don't draw it out
for me i get very frustrated so
the context the physiological uh aspects
that come with physique prep really do
make it a very unique
context to talk about